i'm talking today about digitalization
of the vivarium
past and present and just to show you
what we'll be going through today here's
the overview
we have different animal room monitoring
systems and then rack and blower units
and i'll be spending a lot of time on
cages
that's my been my passion for many years
and still is
and i think it's an interesting time for
the lab animal community in regards to
opportunities of how things are
progressing technically in that area at
this current
point in time and then we need to talk a
little bit about infrastructure needs
and then operational efficiencies and
potential returns on investments
in relationship to what we are talking
about and relative
unapparent communal efficiencies and
benefits
meaning working with the pis in some of
the ways that some of these caging
systems
can help in other areas of the vibram
rather than just the animals alone
so i'll do a summary and questions at
the end as well
so to start off uh what i'd like to do
is talk about some established and
well-known systems
such as the siemens bas integrated
system
or apogee and then go into edstrom
watchdog
and then air acuity and these were
picked because these are ones that i've
worked with in the past
and know fairly well but it also is an
evolutionary type of approach here
in regards to our digitalization and how
they're working within
the building automated systems and it's
also a way of showing
the technology involved with this
overall
these are fully interactive with the bas
uh the initial
focus was always on animal welfare
components the alarming and ability to
notify
these are still very crucial components
throughout all these systems
and then there have been improved
interactive abilities and remote
capabilities as we've
gone on air conditioning and control
tends to be one of our huge research
resource
consumptions for the animal facilities
and one where we
have a lot of cost in regards overall to
this
it represents a major roi for
institutions with rapid short-term
returns if it can be managed
appropriately
so excuse me just showing some of the
examples here
of an apogee system and that's kind of a
building based system with that
excuse me again and then siemens uh
within their
uh units have developed onto the italian
system
which is more of a uh common
university multi-building uh type system
to go ahead and
manage these and then look at airflows
and needs with that
in essence we're starting to look at
more uh smart building type of
situations here with many different
sensors and ability to go ahead and
control the flows on
more of a need basis especially with
some of the ducting
systems uh in relationship to our
airflows for hoods in other areas within
the biological
confinement or containment facilities
overall
when we start looking at the edstrom
system
and that was predominantly based on more
of a security basis
and looking at room control and ability
to enter the rooms
and then go ahead and monitor who's in
the rooms
as well as frequency of going into the
room security of the room itself
and then adding in the water flow
consumer
concerns and abilities to monitor that
and to keep those
systems monitored and digitalized as
well
there is more evolution with this
they're working to integrate more into
other systems with
this system but essentially it's a
standalone system at this point in time
for them but i think they are moving
toward working more
in other relationships with this at this
area of time
this is still a very good system um it
allows uh
leak control and other issues to be
monitored overall
those are important concerns for us
we're starting to look at more air
quality issues
and really when we start looking at that
air acuity comes into play
and the air qualities that we're looking
at are based on
three or four different basis or three
or four different uh
areas that we're looking at co2 uh
temperature humidity uh of course which
has always been one of the issues but
also
tbocs and being able to monitor the vocs
overall
in being able to go ahead and
accommodate air flows in relationship to
that
what i've noticed a lot in a lot of the
primate facilities that i've
consulted or worked with is where they
are actually able to look at particulate
in particular it is a big issue for us
and then
monitoring or ramping up when there are
high particulate times
and decreasing airflows when there's
decreased particulate times
this is essentially tied into wash downs
and ability to monitor around those and
be able to monitor the air flows around
those and anticipate some of those ahead
of time
so ramping up just before wash downs and
then waiting until those particulate
matter dropping up
and then coming back down to where it is
within control
also with different stocking densities
you will get different co2 levels
they are very good at monitoring that
and looking at the
airflow needs through that and
everything that is related with that
as i mentioned air quality is becoming
more of a challenge
uh across all of the world globally
we still have designated flows in canada
and england
they're on engineering standards still
but i'm understanding that that may move
in the near future here especially with
canada to start in england
possibly follow holding rooms are at
about six to ten
uh the average is eight in terms of room
for air exchanges per hour
and this is based on the rack exhaust
rate and thermal loads
labs tend to be at about two to four the
average of three exchanges per hour
air quality tblcs ammonia co2 and
particulates are
the four areas that are really heavily
monitored here
and demand controlled ventilation is
then allowed uh
the monitoring is about every 15 minutes
with established parameters
and your response times you need to be
able to respond
to changes in that but you don't want to
respond too rapidly
because otherwise you'll never have a
baseline so usually there's a five to
ten minute
uh baseline response time and then
reconfiguration before it is
responding to in that sense with that so
this kind of gets us on to the bas
itself and development and really what
we're seeing now is with smart buildings
there's three emerging
technology trends in building automation
and cloud computing is one of them
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
and then connectivity and integration or
the internet of things
and that's really what we're starting to
talk about with some of the air flows
and some of the different particulate
matter sensing co2 sensing
that we're seeing in some of the space
areas
for the lab animals so this is
building into a concept the internet of
things that is
coming very rapidly into our areas of
technology
and we need to understand this and and
hopefully help with this overall
as another example i wanted to go into
the rack blower
unit digitalization in the circa of 1990
ibc's
with their introduction then there was a
lab animal welfare
emphasis in airflow predominantly in the
alarm
and notification focus with these blower
units the room versus individual rack
individual rack and insurance of backup
power to supply units as well was
another
critical component for the animal
welfare
and with these we also saw a little
better ventilation control per
rack on these uh with than in the rooms
overall
rooms were very hard to control with
everything with that so with individual
ivcs
the racks tend to be the primary control
basis for hvacs
and then what we're seeing is where we
can either duct out into the primary
system
or use these individual blower units and
use them to
uh ventilate this in the cage that way
so siro about 2014 temperature humidity
monitoring emphasis on individual racks
and remote monitoring
um that was something that there were
humidity additions available they needed
water supply to
the units so that was uh important as
well in terms of any of the design
function
for facilities in circa about 2016 here
we started to see
individual health monitoring at the rack
level this is not digital but it's
manual
and this is something that could be
digitalized in the future possibly
we'll talk about that in a little bit i
wanted to show some
uh pictures of different rack and blower
unit digitalizations here
so again uh going into main lines this
way for
uh the building facility systems
and uh pulling the exhaust air out with
that
or going ahead and bringing the
exhaust air into the room via some of
the blower units
so there are many different
configurations of this and ways to do
this
uh the better ways in some of these
situations
based on noise and vibration is tending
to look at standalone
blower units and wandering or working
with that or
working with the building system itself
where you can hook into that
so these are things that we need to
think about when we're designing
facilities and
we're working toward uh developing the
best
rack system and air quality to the
animals with that
the blower unit digitalizations you can
see here that we have the wi-fi
unit setups and these again were uh
are very popular and are have the
ability to
individually set different flow rates
for different racks
and alarms for different racks and the
ability to correct those remotely as
well
uh in relationship to the digitalization
of these
and the ability to use wi-fi components
with this
overall with the humidity and
temperature
again these are uh getting more advanced
as
we progress and in the nordic areas
areas of high altitude these are very
critical and important
a lot of times our building systems
can't keep up with the need for the rack
uh in regards to individual cages
especially
so these systems are becoming more
popular and you're starting to see these
more prevalent throughout the community
these can be either locally or centrally
controlled
and looking at remote now with some of
these as well
in relationship to the digitalization
again with the focus on animal welfare
with this
the other area that i mentioned earlier
was the health monitoring on the racks
so we're seeing a lot of the uh ead now
being used or the exhaust air
dust um these systems are built into the
plenums
and then have filters that are detecting
what is going on with that exhaust air
dust or collecting that exhaust air dust
is what i should
uh properly say here and there isn't
technology at this point in time where
it can automatically
say that there are problems or anything
along those lines
but there is other technology out there
that is being looked at
by uh several folks and several
companies
to evaluate the possibilities of having
automated systems for this in the future
so this is something else that is
exciting and possibly coming down line
in the future in relationship to this um
we're seeing some of this also
with the possibility of looking at this
in regards to
the zebra fish tank setups as well
and monitoring them and looking at
automation of that
uh in regards to some of the results we
might get from that
so what i really want to spend time on
is cage division
digitalization and when we start talking
about cage
digitalization i'm really talking about
automated home page monitoring and
technology evolution here
uh really if we want to say what is the
first
way that we monitor cages or animals
uh continuously 24 7. i think we would
have to agree that telemetry was the
basis of that in starting
early beginnings where we could go ahead
and monitor
the physiological aspects of an animal
24 7 via telemetry and still do in many
cases
what we did see is with this
early evolution there were problems with
battery systems implanting these and
others
and this has evolved now to where some
of these units are materially less
they work off uh charging systems
underneath
the cages themselves um and can be
implanted in animals that way so there's
been quite a lot of digitalization
uh for the animals and for the caging in
regards to that
and some of that is emf based related to
those charging systems
there's better and more advanced
progress with behavioral studies
and then doing video analytics and this
was a neural
science drive with this with some of the
behavioral components
and then developing algorithm programs
based off of
the video diagnosis
and looking at what type of behavior or
aspects are occurring with these animals
with that
uh this is primarily study focused and
then what we were seeing is uh then with
this
uh the ability for some of the
algorithms to be quite sophisticated
and be able to tell us what type of
specific
type of behaviors the animals are having
most recently we started seeing the
electronic magnetic fields the low
electronic magnetic field development
and usage for management and study use
the advantage of emf or lemf
is that it allows both management
of the cage and study evaluations as
well
so it has a kind of a dual focus that
way and i'm going to spend
a fair amount of time talking about the
emf
uh abilities with the technology and how
that works
and also comparing that to some of the
other video systems
and other ways of doing behavioral
analysis with that
animal welfare focus predominantly with
these automated home cage systems
the continuous nature of those allows 24
7 evaluation for animal movements and
then
also in some cases the cage environment
emphasis on better study conductance
continuous study data in the home cage
so you're not having to move animals out
disrupting those animals and causing
complications in regards to
the stress that the animals might have
or uh the
non-acclimation of this different study
apparat eye that they might be moved
into
and more recently we've been seeing emf
cage management
uh with this in terms of the ability to
actually determine when cage changes or
cage changeout cycles should be
determined so we'll
evaluate that and look at that as well
here in this presentation
there's opportunities in all of this for
great resource savings labor
and consumables as well as the ability
to have better reproducibility of data
on data sharing overall
some of the home cage monitoring systems
are mentioned here
and looking at the technology we can see
that a lot of it is video based
and rfid chips you can individually
identify animals
in that but also their beam being
breaking vibration systems
um there is also some
uh gas monitoring for metabolic needs
that way too with some of these systems
and the very last one down there with
the technologies the emf and again i'll
get into that more but this is a a
caging system that or a technology
that's fairly new
uh in regards to uh being used in this
manner
and it's been eurocentric predominantly
but it's really coming over to north
america now we're seeing this more and
more now here in north america
so what do these look like here are some
of the cages
there are some with the video rfids as
you can see in the upper left hand
corner there
the bean break vibration is kind of in
the middle there
another uh video our non rfid but just
video system here is on the upper
right and if we look at some of the
metabolic cages here
uh like this one in the lower left hand
corner
you can see here that really there's
some uh changes in regards to the actual
holding cage
uh from what you would expect for being
a normal cage
uh the one thing about the emf system is
this allows a normal cage being placed
into its holding environment and then
the environment
measures the activity and measures the
animal much the same as these video
systems are doing here
and here where the home cages are
the home cage itself what we would
describe as a home cage
but we're not altering the tops nor are
we altering uh the cage itself and then
letting the animal live in there and
acclimate for three or four weeks
they are the cage it's already
acclimated and this
is a great time savings in the
facilities
in regards to acclimation periods and
stabilization periods for the animals
overall so um i just wanted to clear
that up and make sure people had a good
understanding of that because there is a
lot of variety
in what is defined as a home cage system
at this point in time
the cage digitalization itself if we're
looking at that
you can actually monitor animals for
behavior and welfare components
and then the environment and welfare
management again with some of the caging
systems like
using the emf systems for that
it allows uh cape cage inventory
management and resource allocations as
well
adds to it enhances automation support
of the internet of things overall we're
working with those so really for 50 plus
years
the mouse cage has been a box and we
haven't done a lot with that box what if
you could provide information to the
user like the betting condition
cage change scheduling animal activity
or
lack of activity and what if the cages
were really based on need
criteria rather than calendar and i
think this is an
important concept here we're really
starting to see more and more of this
in vivariums now where people are
looking at criteria rather than calendar
for years we've used
calendars and there's been huge wastes
in regards to the calendar-based systems
and the ability to manage those systems
uh well
in regards to the resources so what is
considered a dirty cage is
is a dirty cage reproducible in regards
to different facilities
and again each facility will have its
own definition
the ability to go ahead and say what a
dirty cage is
is something that you know the system
should be able to do
can we reduce the risk of the animal
allergy exposures
and how can we reduce that risk overall
by lack of
changing cages too often or having
animals exposed too often overall from
moving the animals from one page to
another
or into study experimental areas
with that a researcher doesn't have to
worry that his or her mice were being
stressed by cage changes and could
collect data in a home cage would be
something that would be very
optimal as well research and management
can accurately tell when each cage
change occurred to enhance study
management and study
correlations overall so this is
important i think too for everyone
involved
inter cage monitoring the betty
conditioning modules could
increase efficiency by changing washing
based on need
and we'll get into a specific study that
i'll show you that
and what that actually means in terms of
a decreased amount of cage changing and
combining intercage monitoring with
complete
page change combines benefits overall
same technology that monitors the
betting can collect other data uh
the systems are quite varied that way we
can look at activity
presence of food water and this is being
shown here
in regards to how some of the food and
water can be evaluated
uh in these systems with the infrared
beam technology
and then indications when those are
issues of
a alert overall with a red light
indicator
the other thing i'd like to point out is
that not only does it measure
that if there's a water bottle presence
but the actual
correct positioning of a water bottle
not put in upside down
and the level of water within the water
bottle as well
these are all management concerns that
we've had in many different facilities
and this is something that can give
great relief
when you're having a system that will
allow some of that to be
measured so some of the questions that
may come from
our facility managers did i remember to
put that water bottle back on would i
just explained
are we going to have time to prepare for
a lack is there absolutely no way i'm
going to have time
enough time today to do census so what
am i going to do if
ryan called out sick these cages new
york really need to be changed today
his work distributed evenly throughout
the staff
did bob really change all those cages
today
when is this mouse going to have her
pumps great question
uh when where is dr winter's cage of
important mice we've never had that
question right from anybody
are we wasting food or bedding
and how much food bedding do i need to
order how many cages do i have right now
how long has this mouse been dead is
this mouse acting crazy
or is it me am i going to have to
justify more staffing
or how can i justify even more staffing
and is this guy ever going to stop
asking questions so i hope i didn't
cause any anxiety
in folks with all of these mentioned
questions here but again these are
common questions a lot of things that we
do within the facilities can be
answered through some of the
technologies
that we have available to us one of the
things that we
need to start thinking about is how to
let it go in terms of
worrying too much and there's a great
book out there called getting things
done the art of stress-free productivity
i would recommend it as a read to all
who are listening
and a lot of times what we want to do is
uh
you know we kind of register problems in
our minds and we always think about
those problems but we know it's not a
big problem but
you know we're not going to go ahead and
spend all our time on it but we actually
do
we kind of keep coming back to that and
everything that way so
if there's one thing we can do the
happiest people are those who can do it
with the limit of their ability
and we can be completely present we can
be all there we just need to let it go
and we need to give all our attention to
the opportunity before us
not worry about those other little
things that can be handled other ways
and we really need to focus on letting
it go
and we can rely on technology
one of the things that our community is
not
real good at is going ahead and moving
forward with technology
in a rapid fashion or an acceptable
fashion in a lot of ways
so really the advantages of the
technology
is the security the consistency
the efficiency and then the options that
it'll it allows us to go ahead and
really pick through in ways that we want
to manage
and we can best manage with what
resources we
have so having that in mind
um there's some
ways that we can go ahead and look at
cage digitalization
and looking at the real thing here is
the concept of the internet of things i
don't know how many folks have heard of
this term before but it's really
coming on and it's really the
interconnect connectivity of processes
and ability to plan and allocate
resources efficiently and effectively
and there's a lot of interplay here then
with smart technology in relationship to
this
in the internet of things and being able
to do a lot of analytics
and being able to interplay with those
analytics and look at the best path
forward in a lot of oath conditions
with the interdec introduction of the
internet of animals
i wanted to talk a little bit about a
paper that had come out
in 2016 animal research the three r's
and the internet of things opportunities
and oversight
international pharmaceutical development
uh steve mimi and dale
davies were the authors of this
wonderful article it really talked about
standardizations of global data
collections and analytics and increased
sharing
but it also alluded a lot to the ability
to improve welfare and care and better
understanding
through regional effects of
environmental variables and remote
bivariant monitoring as well
allowing us better reactivity and
collaborations than in looking at how
those different areas are one of the big
things we are seeing is a lot of issues
with reproducibility
reproducibility is a concern at several
levels
but understanding where the concerns are
is difficult at times and these systems
are very helpful in understanding how
some of those concerns are developed in
where they really are
so we can sustain and support uh
research utility husbandry veterinary
care
ethics is framed by the three hours
through use of a lot of this technology
that's out there with that
within with the internet of things we
also can talk about the internet of
animals which was introduced
back in uh 2016 as well
and this was an interesting concept in
that we're talking about wearables or
genetically engineered animals geotag
monitored and interconnected
where we can monitor some of the field
studies of how
ecology is changing and then the
massive movements of wild animals and
then also go back into owner and
veterinary communications and look at
those type of
inner reactions there so it really gets
down to how granular can we go
can we go to the internet of the
librarian can we start looking at
how we interplay within the vivarium and
how changing one thing affects several
others down the line
and how this affects things globally as
well with those internets
uh with the internet of the vibram and
the ability for some of the global
data analysis and work that way
so if we talk about the internet of the
vibram one of the things that
i wanted to propose was looking at the
very basics and very baby steps and
starting with cage change out management
how would that work we could start
looking at dirty cage units
self-identified
then cage out units and inventory
identified and resources for those cages
house identified initiation with a
personal resource management system to
go ahead and allow
personnel there for the cage changeouts
and then schedule of the
gauge unit delivery change out and then
delivery to cage wise schedule and
perform
so in speaking of baby steps what i want
to do is take us to a facility that is
in prague
czechoslovakia and talk about what they
have done
at this particular facility which is the
institute of molecular genetics
this is a facility that has had a lot of
background in regards to going ahead
and developing their
their uh supply of mice
to all of europe and they're a breeder
uh facility uh they have a lot of
transgenics there
they also run a mutant colony there and
they're also
a phenotype core so they're very well
known they are a center of excellence
with this but they were running out of
space and in addition to running out of
space
they were running uh into some issues of
not having a barrier in their
experimental facility which then caused
some contamination issues
so long story short they built a new
facility
that new facility i'm sorry here's the
indications for their uh eurocentric
supply for mice that way and
the new facility is actually in investec
which is about nine miles south of
prague
uh this facility is called bioc biosieve
is uh
several different institutions that have
gotten together
that have supported this it's a four and
four floor animal facility
uh new as of 2016 they're still
building and developing in the facility
it is both a barrier breeding facility a
barrier experimental facility
and they have a very good quarantine
there capacity of this facility is about
13 000 cages of mice and about
33 3 400 cages of rats
so looking at this facility we've got
several different areas of it this is
one of the mouse areas here outlined in
red
this is another uh i'm sorry this is a
rat area outlined in red here
and then this area is actually a dvc
strictly using
the dvc caging the emf gauging
in this area here this little area is a
test area for
looking at the caging it's outside of
the barrier area this whole
area is the barrier breeding facility at
the bottom floor of this
facility their cage wash is actually
two floors up and they
moved the dirty cages from that area on
up into the
main uh cage wash area from there
so looking at this i wanted to then dive
into how the
dvc cage itself works and the dvc cage
is based upon
a developing an electromagnetic field
and then measuring that
electromagnetic field this is an
extremely
low very tiny electromagnetic field that
is much less than what we are exposed to
on a daily basis overall
um it's done by having a current go
through
a electrical plate and then you develop
a
basic electromagnetic field from that
there are 12 sensory uh primary sensory
receivers here and uh in the in the
electric plate
these electric plates are underneath
each holding cage in the rack
so the rack is of normal size and
dimension and
density and the cages then sit on top of
these
uh electromagnetic uh plates if you will
electric plates and the elf which is uh
impacted by dietetic materials like mice
will then give a different signal coming
back from
the animals that way when they're in the
presence of one of those
proprietary sensors there's 24
7 continuous welfare checking and auto
phenotyping
uh in regards to this so
realistically in showing you more
diagrammatically here
what will happen with the signals when
you have an mpk
cage with dirty bedding presence of an
animal animal moving away
in cage with wet bedding now i think one
thing that can be confusing is that
these
areas here both the animal movement and
the cage
evaluation the substrate evaluation
is done simultaneously through
algorithms so this system allows
simultaneous
algorithm interpretation of both animal
movement
and of the cage condition very important
in terms of the management
as well as the activity of the animals
overall
so going back into the bio sieve
facility and their specific area with
the
dvc system or the emf system
what was done first was a learning phase
so 20 cages with two
animals then 20 cages with three animals
20 cages with four animals and 20 cages
with five animals
this declared what a dirty cage was
for the system based on density based on
these densities overall
so each individual facility is going to
have their own sop
for how dirty a cage is and
this system will allow you to have that
diversity in regards to what a dirty
cage is
so you can go ahead and direct the
system
and the system learns as well as it's
in progress as to what dirty cages are
overall
with this um after that had been done
the first phase was running for 89 days
without using the dvc turned on this was
the
based system and giving an idea of how
many cages were actually
changed in that period with the amount
of cages
in the area the other uh
next phase that was done was with the
dvc on
and then this was going ahead and
looking at criteria based changes
again in 89 day period and looking at
comparisons then from period one to
period two
the density stocking densities that we
were looking at in here
in regards to total again this was an
area that could hold up to about six
thousand cages but at the current time
they were still building
so the caging that they had there is
about 2400
then with one animal two animal three
animal four animal and five animals you
can see the stocking densities here
and then the breeding cages that were
involved with those two
there is a proponents of one animal here
a lot of these were individual
transgenic males
and females with their pups overall so
that's why you're seeing a higher
incidence with that
a lot of uh what would you would need to
look at in your own facility is what
these densities are within your own
facility that's a very critical aspect
of this overall
what i'm going to show you next is
probably the most important slide
overall
for this uh particular set and this is
the slide that
shows the differences than in terms of
the cage change interval comparison
on the average the total average
uh with different stocking densities
across the board
we were seeing 13.4 days on a 14-day
change cycle with the bbc system
you were getting then 23.29
days uh related to that so almost a
10-day increase there
but again if we get into the data and
really look at one animal per cage there
was a 13-day
increase there with two animals per cage
realistically we're looking at about a
12-day increase here
uh with three animals per cage we're
looking at about a 10-day increase here
so again when we got down into the four
and five animals the
the differences were not that great but
there still was a
increase here and again depending on
your stock and strains of animals these
were predominantly c-57 black sixes or
valve c's
if you're dealing with other stocks and
strains that may be
more higher producers of urine
and issues that way you may see a
decrease in the four animal and five
animal cage change period here based on
the dirtiness uh that you want
overall it may be more effective in
evaluating that and doing that for you
so
that's again looking at animal welfare
with that
the big thing here is there was a 40
reduction overall that we're talking
about with that
so we're seeing a 40 reduction uh for
the animals
uh in relationship to that wanted to do
the math for you actually
uh that was an approximate 40 it was
actually a 42.47 percent
and again if we go back and look at with
five pages and do the
uh actual math related to that what
we're looking at in terms of the
cage change savings for the area
uh based again upon the 5000 cages
and based again upon these averages that
we have of stocking densities and those
stocking densities
staying in the same areas we would have
five fifty seven
thousand eight hundred and thirty four
saved
cage changes so that's pretty important
number
and going forward with that then in
regards to that number
uh one of the things that i think we
need to keep in mind here
is that we could be seeing
uh in terms of washing and animal
holding area for
the actual savings in time
of a hundred seconds so a time motion
study was done
and this was split between clean cage
transport and dirty cage
transport and again that's going to be
quite variable in all your facilities
so it was better to do this uh in not in
terms of money but actually in terms of
looking at time and what was uh
looked at for this hundred seconds
overall
was that um the
age system here
the cage system here
okay if we're looking at the amount of
seconds that we're splitting out here
uh is that we're at 76.04
for the clean aspect and 23.99
for the dirty aspect so this translates
then into actually
how many hours per annum
and how many days per annum as well in
relationship to those specific areas
uh moving forward on that and looking at
then
what that would be overall depending on
if you're on an eight day bronzer eight
hour per day
work day or a seven hour per day work
day
this could either be 48 days or 55 days
for the dirty technician
time only for the clean technician time
if you're looking at that we're seeing
that this could be at 158 days
or 174.6 days if it's a seven
hour per day versus an eight hour per
day
there's a lot of variability with that
again so the one thing that we
don't have a lot of variability with is
how many um
[Music]
how much substrate it would change would
save and that substrate is about
11 200 kilograms of substrate
so all in all there's quite a
significant savings outlet
i want to point out that this was done
uh
in collaboration there were other groups
that were working on this as well
what i've shown you is the most recent
data but bioserve is a group we've just
looked at
we'll look at another group here shortly
these are all european groups here
whereas this here tends to be the u.s
contingency right now so there is active
group working
overall with this and perspectives from
leadership in regards to
uh the netherlands and london university
um just wanted to show you that there
was an experimental design for a very
similar
beta study in regards to changing uh not
using as many cages
only 60 cages and then doing this with
10 animals with the different stocking
densities
and then getting the results in
relationship much similar to what was
done in the previous study
phase one phase two and phase three and
getting ideas of
uh the differences in regards to the evc
directed uh
cage changeout and cage change algorithm
as a final phase three
and the bottom line in this was that
there was good validation
correlation with what we had just seen
from bioserve
so this is uh and others that i've
talked to
um have gone up as high as uh 65
and others have gone as low as 30 on
this so again there's there's
variability here
and uh i think the bottom line with all
this is there's a significant reduction
of cage changes per unit of time while
maintaining acceptable cage conditions
through use of digitalization systems uh
for the caging overall
the translation if they if with the
particular netherlands study that was
done
was looking at a 12 000 cage change then
if that was being done
and this gives you some data in
relationship to that uh as an estimated
savings overall not realistic the other
one from bioseed was actually realistic
because of the amount of cages
that were being used in those areas and
how many were being put through there so
again it goes back to your stocking
densities though and moving that way
the other thing that this allows is we
go from this calendar system that we've
been indoctrinated in for many years
and been non-flexible with to a system
that now allows us
uh to have quite a lot of variation in
and ability
and latitude in how we use our resources
i should point out as well that the
system is careful not to go ahead and
save up a
3000 cage change for one day um they
will anticipate if there are a bunch of
dirty cages coming forward so again this
is the
uh learning phase that we're talking
about and machine learning
uh within the system itself and when
that system starts seeing that it
pushes some cage changes forward um it
also recognizes weekends and holidays
and allows then uh to work around those
if you will
and what i mean by that is moving cage
change forward
or uh going ahead and anticipating how
dirty those cages might get
and still being acceptable though but uh
keeping them at a level where they can
go ahead and move around that
so um the system is very sophisticated
in regards to this
but it is uh user friendly and has a
great interface as well
in the ability to do that so
going forward and again kind of
concluding with this
talking about this cage change wash
initiation
uh schedule and going through all of the
aspects of that for a
internet of the vibram and the smart
building
we would need to then go ahead and tie
that into the cage wash
and evaluate how many dirty units are
coming down
have resources available for that and
then allocate those resources and be
able to move them through that way
and with some of our software systems in
terms of management we're actually able
to start to do some of this already
so it's a very exciting time for us i
think in regards to all of this
so what i did want to mention is that we
talked only about
um the uh betting conditions so far
uh and a little bit about animal
activity but there are several other
things that can be done with these
systems with these digital systems as
well
and i think that's important we also
talked a little bit about the food and
water levels but
there are many things that can be done
with these and i think that they can be
add-ons and expansion as well
so it's an exciting time for us in the
lab animal community
i wanted to get into a little bit more
on the activity and to show you a little
bit of how that works so again we said
these algorithms can be run the same
time that we're seeing
with the cage change or with the cage
conditions
and if we look at the drop of that
signal and how many signals we're
getting from just
one of the sensors that's 240 samples in
one minute
uh we're looking at about 3 000 samples
per minute
in relationship to the board and that
translates out to many signals per hour
but i want to compare this to the video
systems
and have you recognize that with the
video systems the amount of data that's
actually
being pushed forward there is much
higher than what we are seeing here
with some of the um with the emf system
overall so there is a lot of data uh
you need to understand how you're gonna
manage that data um
and it's really important as to who has
access to the data do the investigators
need access to the data
obviously management managers in the
facility will need access to the data
and how often do they need that data
and then how long are you going to store
the data i think as we
move forward with these mega data sets
and other
large data compilations that we're
seeing
storage of data is becoming more costly
actually than
some of the hana using some of the
systems to analyze
the data itself and to move forward with
it so
this is uh something that should be
looked at from the administrative level
regarding this overall getting back into
the
heat map and talking about activity
levels we can see here that on a heat
map
and that just shows where the red is is
it's more active
we're having a cage change or monitoring
a cage here over a 10-day period
and during that in that day period on
day three there was a cage change
none and what is readily apparent from
this heat map
is that you can see uh related to that
cage change
that there's a lot more activity up here
uh than there would be in
other days that would not have as much
activity there
so anytime you change a cage the bottom
line of this is that you're creating a
lot more
stress on those animals and there's a
lot more activity for either
uh fair hormone marking or marking the
cage on those animals a lot
more increased activity and disruptions
where
normally in the night time there's high
activity
and that's where you see mostly activity
and actually it's kind of a biphasic
early on
and then later in the night you see that
occurring uh right before the morning
time period and kind of a feeding area
here as well
um and it's interesting to be able to
see that and notice that in
different streams uh that we do have so
the um one thing that we wanted to look
at
is what happens if you do diet
restriction what cause
what are the activity changes that might
be occurring with diet restriction this
was done
uh through the the consortium that i
showed you earlier
and this was done up in sweden at the
karolinska institute
and what we were actually seeing is
where when i showed you the first heat
map you saw that during the night there
was great
high activity during the day very low
what we're seeing is a reversal of that
in the diet restriction
animals now these animals were fed at
10 i think it was 10 o'clock
overall so that really caused
some issues in regards to i'm sorry they
were fed at noon
so these animals were fed at noon so
what you're seeing is where these
animals are hungry and they want to get
fed
so instead of waiting uh into the night
period to eat
they immediately went to the feeder and
is this affecting then their circadian
rhythm
and some of the issues that might be
behaviorally important for the
investigator and some of the areas that
they're looking at
so really we need to be cognizant of
this and be very careful of how we're
feeding animals on diet restriction and
when we feed them
uh related to their normal activity
period and how that occurs
one of the other things that i wanted to
show here was a breeding
algorithm and show how this could be
used to help
predict when partition might occur in
caging
and what we see are a couple different
things here with this is where the
animals are starting to congregate in
one corner of the cage predominantly
and this is an impaired system uh we are
working on
harem as well and getting better uh
definition with the harem systems and
how those are working
but what we are seeing is within uh
these systems is where
they're going into the corners of the
cage and staying in that corner and
that's
a high predictability of when that
happens but even a better predictability
of this and more effective is the
average velocity of the animal how fast
it's moving
and as it decreases its velocity there's
a higher predictability for the
partition as well
so both of those together going in the
corner and decreased velocity
gives a high very high confidence rate
for when
partition will occur in these animals
another thing that can be used for the
activity monitoring is phenotyping
a lot of places are looking at many
different
transgenics and what we are seeing is a
huge increase with crispr crass 9 and
transgenic
creation so as a result of that going
through and doing the phenotyping on
these is very important
this particular one is with the als
syndrome and looking at sod 1 mice which
are a model for als and being able to
predict when
these animals are developing this
disease
process because the pathology often
precludes or is
earlier much earlier on than the
clinical signs
and it's important for the research to
be able to find the pathology first
and then to address that pathology so by
looking at animal movement we can
actually
understand when the pathology is
starting
and do this at a much earlier time
period as being shown here
with the one animal sod animal two sod
animals
and then again in a different graphical
depiction here showing
affected animals uh being able to be
seen much
earlier than when uh the control animals
are there as well
so um it's a definite advantage for the
investigators
who are active in this area and who need
to have earlier
uh clinical symptomology uh or actually
pathology identified
and not just rely on the clinical
symptomology because often by the time
they're showing the clinical signs it's
too late for some of the
things that they want to intervene with
my last part of this presentation will
just be talking about stroke
and evaluating some of the stroke models
here
or using this system to help evaluate a
stroke model overall
and being able to see what how that can
be used for intervention
uh in the stroke model and evaluation
so this was doing a timed 30 minute
unilateral occlusion the middle cerebral
artery and the design of the experiment
was doing some
behavioral testing ahead of time
baseline then doing the actual
stroke and then going ahead and giving
different diets in relationship to
stroke therapies overall and how
effective
these diets might be these are
antioxidant diets they're based on
fish oils omega-3s actually heavy in
that so
this is some of the things that were
being looked at with this some of the
behavior tests that were done were open
field roto-rod grip strength pull test
and model object recognitions so these
are the control diet was your basic
diet that way then the forsten diet was
the
antioxidant omega-3 rich uh fish oil
diet that way
in an open field activity when that was
done and
by the postdocs here uh velocity and
distance walked after stroke there was
no dietary effect
uh noticed with this um and then 14-day
uh post-stroke uh really again no
dietary effect was noticed with this
and the pole testing on this mouse and
the
foursome turned a little bit faster and
they had improved motor
coordination uh and actually with the
cerebral blood flow um what we're seeing
here is that there was a
increase of cerebral blood flow with the
force and at day 35 in that right
hemisphere
right hippocampus at day 35 with the
animals that way
so the question came up well what about
the open field uh results and could
there be a better way to look at this
maybe with the dvc
and so there was a little bit of things
that they wanted to look at
in terms of the distance
the velocity and then the angulations uh
using the dvc system
and then comparing that somewhat to the
open field overall
one of the big things that this did
allow as well
is to look at where the major activity
was when the lights were off
as we would have assumed there was a lot
more activity overall
on the in the animals across the board
both in controls and in the dietary
animals that way
activation on the boards in regards to
centers corners walls and global cage
much more activity in the evening hours
again uh
and again uh into the corners
we seem to see more because again these
guys are more tactic that way
so the comparison uh if we look at
lights on lights off
and in the diet and control groups we
could see that there was much higher
activity in the dietary
groups in the evenings overall
activation on the boards again
showing some of the activations with the
different control diets and then test
diets
at beginning and at the end of the
studies showed that there was more
activations there
distance walk displacement length
looking at it then with the open
field during the day in the dvc at night
uh the distance walked increased over
time
during the night uh for this and it's
almost a
reversal of what was being seen here
with the open fields
this is pretty critical for their study
and for some of the things they were
looking at
and then activities in the corners we
saw more activity
on the force and diet and corners
especially at the night time
so again looking in the evening rather
than the daytime and evaluating these
animals in their proper
time period of when their behavior is
the most active or their
normal behavior we might say uh is
occurring
rather than in daytime when it's
abnormal or their nighttime
behavior where they're resting usually
so
really critical for the study and it
increased
at night again due to the diet that way
one of the questions that came up by the
investigator
was is there more stress with some of
these different
testing modalities that they're doing uh
the different behavior testings
so one of the things they looked at was
how much activity there is post-testing
and then correlating that to a
possibility of it being a stressful
event if there's higher activity
because of the fact of what we had seen
uh actually with cage changes and others
where
animals are aroused and they're more
active and they're a little more
stressed
in relationship to what they're doing
that way it may take a little longer to
settle down
post uh the studies that way so in doing
this the stress activity levels four
hours before
four hours before ever after every test
uh
no particular stress returned to the
home cage after testing with the
uh open field or the the uh
pull testing but the grip test was uh
somewhat uh
stressful it appeared because it was
a quite an increase there was a slight
increase
in the neural imaging and roto-rod but
again the grip test was most apparent as
being
most creating most and then the
advantage of the
uh dvc over open field is that uh
we are looking at where monitoring the
subtle subtle
changes in activity walking patterns
location animals
can't be detected in the current
experimental settings with the open
field
last week all mics were more active
faster longer distance in the first week
monitoring activity before and after
tests show a significant increase in
movement during the first four hours
after the grip test compared to four
hours before the test so
is it stressful you know again that's a
consumption there it's not a proven
entity
uh but it would seem that way uh animals
and control diets sit more in corners
they're less active and have preference
for left turns in the first week
compared to the force
diet so again this is a valuable data
for the investigator
for looking at that type of dietary
replacement and correction for stroke
and also for people who have stroke so
what we can say in our summary slide
here is that cage automation is evolving
it is at the internet of the vibram i
would like to say
i think we're starting toward that um
we're
nowhere near it at any point now but um
you know we're doing baby steps and one
of the first baby steps is this cage
technology and looking toward that and
moving
in that direction uh by varying
architecture and design components need
to be able to incorporate and support
these systems in regards to
uh the new facility designs and
retrofitting
and being able to support some of the
high databases that we need and then
how are you going to store that data and
where are you going to store that data
the advantage of this is dual room usage
both holding and study
allows rapid study scalability and
flexibility in regards to using
some of the digitalized caging for study
results
at this point in time i'd like to thank
you for this long presentation i didn't
mean it to be this long it just got that
way
and then i'll take any questions that we
might have at this time
thank you john hassanall for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question drop
down box located on the far left of your
presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
what safety testing has been done with
these continuous home cage systems
the with a lot of the video systems and
the metabolic systems the infrared beam
brake systems
vibration systems i'm not aware of much
uh
safety testing that's been done or uh
evaluation of those uh with the emf i'm
more familiar with that
and i can um say that the company that
has been working with this
has done a year-long study uh with
their with the emf at a level that would
be used during study
uh looking both clinical pathology and
pathology
this was presented in the uh villasa
meeting symposium that was held in
brussels
and uh the results of that showed that
there were no significant
uh pathological changes either clinical
pathology or gross
or histological pathology uh related to
its system's use it's also had the emf
itself has had a lot of discussion in
regards to
uh phone technology although that is a
much higher
uh hertz level than what we're seeing
uh with this technology and um again
there's been extensive testing and other
things have been done with that
um and as we all know we all are
relatively easily using our phones still
and and have that technology in hand
most of the time of the day
so i i can fairly safely say here that i
think it's a very safe system
and uh we have not seen issues with this
at all
hopefully that answered the question
thank you our next question is what is
the roi that you would see
with the dvz component for just doing
the cage changes
good question but um so there's a lot of
variables here
and one of the things that we really
need to think about
is each institution and the stocking
densities at each institution
as i showed you in the presentation if
you have a lot of
ones twos or threes your roi is going to
be
really good because it's going to be
pretty quick in terms of how high
uh your changeout
intervals are going to be increased um
related to that fours and fives
uh stocking density you may not have as
great
a return of investment on those
over time but i think uh you know i
think the question was just for the cage
change out
so that's you know one part of it um the
other thing that i showed in the
presentation that i didn't elaborate on
was that was just a technician time
that i was showing a good savings on
there in terms of the days
what i did not show was utility savings
wear and tear on the caging
uh the amount of caging backup that you
need in terms of stock of stock
for cage changeouts um and then also
uh wear and tear on caging equipment uh
the cage washers themselves
uh related to how much caging you're
putting through so
um that's just one area that you're
saving with this so i
i think there probably are further uh
talks that could be done on that
and and really evaluate that as well uh
in relationship to that
so it's it's hard to say there is no one
set number
you can come up with but it would be
more of a formula
uh looking at first the stocking
densities and kind of getting that in
hand and then going ahead and putting in
the other variables there
um are you working on a seven hour work
day or eight hour work day what you know
what's the actual real
realistic workday that you have there
those are all factors as well
thank you our next question is how do
you engage
the care staff towards these systems and
encourage their acceptance
yeah i remember
when the first time the staffs
were starting to see the robotic washers
coming through
and that um you know
walking through alas uh the
illas shows uh with staff and and
uh getting their feedback from that and
quite a lot of worry on their part in
terms of being replaced
i think you know one of the things that
we have to encourage
[Music]
everyone about is that are we doing
everything that we should be doing
currently
in the facilities in relationship to the
time allocations that we have
and then how thoroughly can we really
look at a cage
uh in relationship to uh you know all
the cages in the facility and really
evaluate those over time
i think that's an important concept for
the staff to have as well and that
we're augmenting them not replacing them
this is an augmentation this should help
them
in what they're doing and that this
would be
benefiting welfare as well for the
animals
in relationship to when we can find
these cages that are either dirty or
flooded or
other problems that way and react to
them in a
timely fashion a lot of these uh the
systems
in europe as they're running now and
some of these in the us
are running in the evenings when no
one's in the facility and the animals
are at their high activity time periods
and then what's happening is um you know
they're they're doing their algorithms
early in the morning and what is a lot
what is happening then is and that's
before the staff comes in
and then they're creating uh you know
the reports
right before the staff comes in so the
staff
has the ability to address these issues
that are found through the systems
right off first thing in the morning
early on
and again that can be adjusted too so
that there could be a
pm shift coming in if there were uh you
know a rack that had extremely valuable
animals but
um i think that the major thing for the
engagement of staff
and encouragement of acceptance here as
i understand the question
is that um the staff is not being
replaced it's augmenting the welfare and
the care of the animals overall and
should be
uh you know accepted more as as we
talked about in the talk
the other good thing to do might be to
take the staff down and walk them
through cage wash
and show you know okay here's you know
100 pages out of these hundred cages how
many of these cages really really needed
to be changed at the calendar
time uh when we're looking at this
and um i've done that in some facilities
and
it's amazing you know the responses you
get is oh my gosh what waste
we're doing here so um those those are
approaches that i
you know that could possibly be used and
things that could be done that way